head coach of the Michigan Wolverines
Jim Harbaugh on the program good morning
coach how are you good damn good to hear
your voice
what time do you wake up usually when
the when the kids wake up the
three-year-olds usually drives it he
gets up pretty early but did and and
then what's what's quarantine like in
the Harbaugh household living the dream
in quarantine a lot of phone calls a lot
of phone calls yeah a lot of phone calls
a lot a lot of doom meetings and staying
in touch with other head coaches in the
Big Ten our athletic department our
coaches on our staff our players and and
recruit so then a lot of conversations
what have you been told well as far as
whether we're gonna play again I mean
that that's the big question in Reed's
mind can we can we play again a state I
think right now we're we don't know
because it's dictated by I think the
simplest answer is if the governor's
allow our gyms to open up then you know
then we should be able to get our guys
back into the waiting room and training
and and then a whole set of other a lot
of smart people working on you know can
we can we eventually play the games you
know I don't think anybody knows that
for sure right now could you see a
scenario though coach we're not every
school in a conference is going to be
playing their football season or
starting on time with everybody else
yeah I could see that I'd be I'd be more
for that you know then been saying all
all all its all can't play then nobody
plays you know then kind of I've never
been a big fan of it but that kind of
thinking yeah because I was wondering
about Rutgers given the proximity to New
York City they might not be able to
start when everybody else does I look at
the SEC and it it feels like the SEC is
probably going to be full speed ahead
pac-12 I think has got some issues with
just proximity of the schools there
I mean it's it's kind of the wild wild
west of trying to figure out who's
playing and how many games you're gonna
play is there gonna be travel with
planes or is it buses and are you sort
of you know sorting this out as well
yeah you know buddy everybody's looking
into that you know it'll be driven a lot
are they're gonna help professionals but
I mean a lot of different scenarios
being playing for it like all options
being looked at the things that you're
saying right now I'm people are looking
at the length of the schedule is it is
it just a conference schedule you know
we do do you play the games and a
certain percentage of the pants can come
or no fans can be in the stadium I mean
all those things are for being talked
about and looked at talking to Jim
Harbaugh Michigan head coach I was
watching the 1995 Pro Bowl festivities
and the long throw competition during
quarantine you'll watch a lot of
different things coach and I got I got
drew bledsoe in there you Brett Favre
Kordell Stewart's in there I think you
threw it 65 66 yards far but I think
blew everybody away
yeah what do you remember about that
remember that was a far as I ever thrown
a ball so I I'm never feeling really
good about myself because throw it
that's part I did and it's kind of a
kind of low wind cheater but yeah well I
watch him far so the long ball went
Randall Cunningham one time saw him so
it's 75 75 or 80 yards and into the wind
that's that was you know Wow gosh that
was amazing stuff best arm you ever saw
wow that's a that's uh mmm that's that's
a toughy um Andrew Luck had great on the
UH the ball came out a lot faster you
know
do it harder than he looked like you was
throwing it was catchable Kaepernick
extremely extremely strong arm yeah guys
it's one of Randall Cunningham hit
that's fluid motion like you like a whip
yeah you know the amazing thing is that
they there's not there wasn't guys that
I came to take it too many guys you
threw it the same you know everybody had
a little bit different different
throwing motion but yeah I was you know
Brett Favre was incredibly strong arm
guy are you still pushing for the Tom
Brady statue on campus yeah yeah I think
that's bittern the greatest player of
all time pretty much left the field well
what what did your Chancellor president
or athletic director say about this uh
being looked into
[Laughter]
Jonas Salk's I think we I think we
should give us how many Super Bowls did
Jonas Salk win would you explain explain
this to me because I never heard this
story I don't know if it's true or not
when you were with the Niners when when
Peyton Manning left the Colts he worked
out for the Niners and you were there in
2012 is that were you guys close to
signing Peyton Manning in 2012 we we
were yeah we were we did a workout and
it was down at Duke University and he
threw the ball up great we we were
evaluating the situation recruiting him
we just didn't we didn't want to get
into the the no the but the show of it
you know we're SUVs are pulling up and
you know flying in here and there oh
yeah what was more into the radar but
and we had Alex Smith - who had a great
season for
in 2011 and then Peyton ultimately ended
up decided to go to the Denver but we
were we were our hat was in the ring and
we were talking and but uh yeah we had a
good situation with Alex and and
ultimately Payton chose the Broncos
before I let you go you're proposing
that well I explained it what you want
to allow players to be able to do to go
pro early if they have the I if they had
the talent the opportunity to go pro
right that a player could submit his
name to the NFL Draft after any season
freshman sophomore junior senior or
after a fifth year I mean if the NFL
does draft them then they would become a
pro but the second part is that they can
return to playing college football if
they're not drafted which is right now
that's not the case if somebody submits
their name for the draft they're you
know they're gone so creating more
options and then the third piece of it
is if a player leaves college and
pursues his pro career placement place
pro ball then after his pro career then
he could return to college as a student
and finish his degree at the expense of
the university so options that that
would ultimately give the good player a
shot at a college career shot at a pro
career if good enough and also make sure
that is that the youngster gets used
agree because the numbers are still the
same a minister there's only you know
one and a half percent of NCAA players
are going to play in the NFL and and and
the alarming thing is the amount of of
youngsters that come out you know early
for the draft and then player don't play
a lot of times that even not even get
drafted about thirty percent go
undrafted that leave after their third
year and then there then it's over there
is no coming back to college there's no
I don't even have the
degree and and you don't have the pro
career so instead of that scenario
taking place the scenario plate taking
place where the where the kids and their
family can have it all and they get
their playing careers and shot at the
pro career and they're going to get
their degree it just makes a lot of
sense and as a a win-win-win for
student-athletes great to talk to you
and hopefully we get this sorted out
soon my best to your father and thanks
for joining us coach that's Jim Harbaugh
Michigan head coach